yeah hello and welcome to this video
this is a video that probably probably
some of you have expected to be out soon
it's the announcement that my Benko
based repertoire against 1d form is
completed released and yeah you can buy
it right now if you like and see
whatever yeah compared for Blacky to
play against 1.d4 so I'm going to show
you a little bit what it's all about
it's released on chasuble this isn't an
opening or it's a site for learning
chess basically it's currently focused
on learning opening variations it's
supposed to be more versatile in the
future but currently you can buy or
enter yourself a chess repertoire for
the opening and learn it so how does it
all work I'm going to log into the site
in order to buy my repertoire you need
to sign up which is free and then you
can buy the repertoire so I'm going to
log in to show you how it is actually
does look like once you're in the site
yes so you would have an overview of
books as it is called which means these
are various repertoire that you could
buy and then learn so there is a couple
of things already released here we have
on genre following you for example did
video another video hint at repertoire
on the Scandinavian that you could could
buy we've got some things here recently
released by trifle Gary Kings crushes of
opening traps and for repertoire and
what is also out now is the Banco based
repertoire that I have produced so how
does it actually look like so if you get
into this repertoire once you have
bought it it gives you gives you this
starting view there's some some
explanation about it gives you some idea
how much content it has just like more
than 300 variations which is a pretty
difficult now to explain how much it is
but it is I can assure you it is quite a
it's a comprehensive repertoire so what
what are you actually going to do with
it once you're here yeah you learn it
this is the thing you have a learn
button here and this is the the key
feature of this side first of all I'm
going to show you what the structure of
the whole thing is so it is some it is
an eight-part release it has an intro
and then we look at the various stages
that that we see from from move one so
I'm looking at everything that white may
play after one d4 with black going for
the Bangko that means we have deviations
on two like d4 Knight f6 Bishop f4 the
London system or the Trump offski or the
various sulphur whatever they they might
try we also have d4 93 93 c5 covered
with all possible of British deviations
on d4 Knight f6 c4 c5 inviting the been
crafted d5 b5 and why just is not played
if I'm playing Knight f3 kind of a
spoiler move not allowing us the gambit
play but also that is covered so if you
look through this repertoire and and
learn it you have a full full complete
answer as a desert also in the title to
one deform so ideally speaking this is
the only thing that you need in order to
play against one deform in an aggressive
and enterprising manner um yeah we have
Fokker no other declines of the gambit
and so on it's all there we also have I
have firm annotated 7 I think it was at
the end it was kind of going up and down
in the suit of games there that show
this is a at times it's very deeply
analyzed games showing ideas and
concepts that happen in those games I
mean I do a lot of this also in the
actual repertoire parts like 2 to 7 but
those games I think a gives additional
value to understand what's going on in
the middle games so how does that
learning actually work so what you what
you can do is you can basically
- in this repertoire you can also click
always click and learn next and it will
show you new variations out of this and
and teach you all the moves and it keeps
track if you if you have basically
learned it or not so how does that work
I'm going to just click learn next and
see what happens okay start learning
let's do it
so this is how it starts and it gives
you here White's move d4 and then you've
got the the experiment explanatory text
this is by the way it's from the intro
there's a brief thing called intro to
the Bangko gambit which gives a brief
overview of all the options that I'm
going to be presented in the later and
single chapters so there's also quick
mode which does the whole thing a little
bit quicker I'm going to not activate it
now it's actually I think the mode that
most people would use at the end but it
probably has very little bit hectic for
the video if you see it at first
so what are you doing now it says d4 you
gonna have six okay so you click Next
you can also press a button and now you
basically sitting here and have to play
move so you should remember okay it was
a knight f6 that's not all that
difficult you know as you see you got
ten points for that so you always gain
and gather points for doing the right
moves and if you don't enter the correct
moves then it actually make takes note
of that and it's going to ask you a
little bit later if you know i doing it
right so it's really a learning tool to
those moves it's not just like passively
watching someone telling you what to do
it's just you have to play the moves
actually so here there's the text but
note that this is the short text from
the intro in the actual yeah the the
meaty versions has much more more pros
so again what now and you saw it was c5
so I'm going to play C 5 I'm getting a
couple of points and now we repeat it
quickly ok Knight f6 Bishop c5 it was C
if I okay so I get some points again now
okay c5 is is the key move we understood
by now so and this is how it works
now you say just learn next
and we get to the next point this is
Bishop f4 now is the next thing I know
this is the into I'm going to switch to
something a little more meteor next now
you always have the text explanations on
the right-hand side what it's all about
and okay so what was that it was a
galaxy 5 right that's easy I tried to
make it compile the the ideas in a way
that it is somewhat Banco Banco type him
so let's let's say we okay for that now
now here's also an overview of all the
single lines in the in the intro yeah as
I said the intro is just a brief
overview of everything if we go back and
you see now that from the intro we've
already seen that progress bar yeah we
already done like maybe this is like 20%
of the stuff and this keep makes you
keep track what you actually have done
this is also an extremely nice feature
if you actually if you take a book and
say okay I'm learning the lines from the
book do you actually know if you have
looked at everything I don't think you
do and here it actually makes sure to
give you a clear feedback if you have
looked at it or not no I know that I
have haven't looked at I don't know
chapter 7 so that's actually going to
into one of the the bigger portions of
this so let's go into the to the main
line that's am and and see how how that
works so we could maybe maybe go here
and I can do it moves let's do it okay
and so we jump right in into this
position we should cancel here yeah I
note that I skipped some some some early
stages but I just wanted to show that
works so okay we have to cancel now huh
so this is the the g3 system yeah
there's a text black having delayed the
caption a 6 it's a bit less dangerous as
the text so I think that as user
information we know we should go d6 so
okay that's t6 we get points for that
okay here we go 9b d7 we don't take a 6
so note that if I play this now it
has wrong the right move is not bd7 it
it shows it again so next time I should
remember that I shouldn't take on a six
there would be one night be six okay so
we go here and now yeah Bishop f5 the
big difference because the bishop is
attacking the rook so we see that in
this particular variation it was very
useful not to have taken only six and
now the right group goes back and we
even get in Knight you form with a very
active position we can look at this
queer this quick mode yeah let's enable
this and same sensei next what move
should I play it was not ready for yeah
you know this is a little bit quicker I
don't have to click Next all the time
it's a little bit quicker so go back
here and hit f5 here where black make
sure that this this Knight is covered so
I find the quick mode has less
repetitions but I think it's probably
what most people will use so castles
should be correct and here it was d6 now
we get the whole thing again
yeah Knight bt7 was the trick yeah don't
take on a six but delay the capture and
here we have Knight b6 for Bishop f5
that was the idea and I think I'm going
to not make a mistake again don't don't
don't think that I that I know all of
her efforts were by heart it's a it's
not it's not that I know everything I
can look at everything but it doesn't
mean that it was going back and have fun
I know that looks repetitive I can
assure you one thing it works you
actually learn this stuff if you have to
put it on the board like two times or
three times it really helps I've checked
this with other repertoire that I don't
know I don't like the Scandinavian and I
actually was able to to reproduce the
moves very very reliably
in that way it really is a more active
way of learning than just looking at
something I mean the thing is if you're
on video if you just watch a video where
someone points our moves
I mean I've done those videos myself I
think they can be effective if you are
really really focused by watching but
it's a different story if you actually
have to put the moves on the board so
and the good thing is it's very easy you
just say learn next whoops and this is
the next the next thing so what is that
ah okay white comes Knight age four and
we go back to f7 why is that
I have we prevent b3 I can there's an
extra note or text there and yeah night
h4 was awesome make sure that Bishop f5
is not happening so we want to go back
here and make sure that what doesn't go
be through now we actually take okay so
let's take the pawn b3 Oh like it's
going back that's interesting okay so we
go back to shoot two to nine f6 haha so
black is actually putting more pressure
on e5 so before and now Bishop is six
aha it says an important resource yeah
why is that important white cannot
cancel anymore so black actually
maneuvered with these pieces covering or
provoking if one Bishop a6 is preventing
canceling so this is important to
remember now let's see if I can actually
reproduce that yes so we had night ft7
preventing the b3 move no castles okay
now we take I'm sorry Queen c2 now we
take white place b3 trying to get that
going
we go back we attacked e5 and ultimately
played Bishop a six
okay so let's make sure that we get it
right
this one we take it and we put more
pressure on the fire so the ultimate
ambition a6 is coming yeah this really
helps I mean it really helps
so one more let's go for one more
aha so that was a six right in d5 well
that looks like a crazy variation okay
so we go in five okay now d4 at the end
um and it says black is fine this line
is just one way to play after Knight
edge for there plenty of alternatives
along the way yeah I mean why this black
is super active in this position I just
if you look at this the white knight
doesn't have a good square we attack a
two with the rook and it's everything is
super active on the black side this is
the the general idea of this repertoire
black always wants to play in a most
active fashion possible so you just have
to do this again to get a couple of more
points so what was that that was a six
right and then d5 it's really a funky
EDM and black has good compensation
after d4 I can easily believe that so is
six and d5 very interesting okay yeah
this is basically how it works if this
item has a couple of more features of
course for example um here you see
review what does that mean you can click
on that okay and it gives you it takes
you back to a certain line and it has a
point it has a point last time I to show
you what happens if I do a wrong move
yeah I played Bishop a6 and now I
remember that this move is correct so it
actually just took me back to something
that I did know
to write it the first time you see your
progress of the whole thing I've now
learned five out of 293 variations it is
quite a bit of material to check out so
it's a it's a really comprehensive
answer to 1d for you see you now I have
a small progress here with this there
there's plenty plenty more to look at
there are also different ways of looking
at the whole thing there's also a
repertoire tree for example available
which means that it has all the lines in
one tree view so you can basically click
click through it like that if you want
to look up a certain thing you can you
can get down for example yeah like if
you want to check how this exactly works
you can click through this and see all
the different variations it's a it's
also very nice tool to work with
note that your own zone have the option
to do to start or take this as a
starting point for your own things yeah
you can also add things if you like so
on I think it's a pretty neat way of
learning the opening if you have never
checked out this way of learning a line
on chasuble um maybe this repertoire is
a good way to start I'm really happy
with the lines in the in the repertoire
in zone I'm willing to play them in
serious chess yesterday I played a neat
game and against a good opponent rated
roughly 2,400 and that tried to play it
with black but he played a very
non-critical variation I can actually
show you what he played so that you see
that it's that it's in my repertoire I
would recommend c5 and he played the
move III which is not very dangerous g6
and yeah he played actually d5 yesterday
so it's not in my repertoire but after
d5 yeah we reach something that I've it
was like d5
Bishop g7 and currently there is this
not part of their patron but this
position I think should be now closed
I probably after castles or something
let's see we had to we had this this
kind of thing yeah and this is this is
in the repertoire so it's just a small
transposition you cannot get all the
move orders in and it's just not
possible so if you are interested in a
complete repertoire because this one
before which is pretty aggressive yeah
with with the Banco and you will be a
pawn down most of the time but you will
also have active positions most of the
time yeah check out the video here on
Chester but I think it's a really cool
way of learning by the way from a
technical point of view I'm - I should I
should show that actually if you go back
to the starting point
it is currently selling at nine dollars
99 and this is a current price so it's a
it's a seal that is active until early
November I think November first not
mistaken it will be $15 after that so if
you are absolutely sure you want to get
it it's a good idea to do that pretty
quickly so you don't actually pay the
higher price at the end it is easy to
pay those kind of repertoires or
chasuble you've got plenty options from
credit card to two other options PayPal
whatever it's it's all in there as far
as I saw so it's um it's it's easy to do
um also and I'd like to add a little
something that Chester but has a very
young yeah good way of treating their
authors so if you buy this it actually
benefits me I mean there are a couple of
a couple of things released on websites
where the author is basically exploited
and this is not the case with this so I
would be very happy from people are
interested in the repertoire give me
feedback also know this is an important
thing this is not something that is set
in stone if somebody would point out a
mistakes or improvements I will
definitely
yeah get them get them integrated into
the repertoire it's a living thing in a
way which means that I'm not going to
like change 90% of it during a month but
if there are really mistakes or things
that should be improved
I will definitely enter them so it's a
it's a very nice thing and the big
advantage over a book which is basically
set in stone okay I hope you like this
this informational video enter my
interested in the repertoire thanks for
watching